So now, you understand regular expressions. You can interpret this pattern. The
one thing I haven't told you about that's important for interpreting this is
this dot here. This doesn't mean just a dot. Depending on the context, it often
means any character other than a new line. So, this regular expression here will
match a whole bunch of strings. Any string that starts with a slash, followed by
any sequence of zero or more letters. So, it wouldn't match the slash by itself.
It would match the slash, followed by any sequence of letters other than a new
line. And when it does the matching, what's contained in the parenthesis will be
the first parameter. And what the application will do is call the get method
from this class, the parameters from the regular expression. In our case, that's
the query for our search. This input is a tuple that can contain any number of
pairs, and each pair a regular expression followed by the name of the class that
will handle patterns that match that. And what the application server will do is
go through the patterns in order until it finds one that matches the query that
came in.